bonsoir le 7 8 sur tv fil 78 et une
heure pour faire le point sur
l'actualité locale en direct si vous
nous rejoignez à 18 heures et ce soir
nous parlerons du plan social annoncé
par alcatel lucent en fin de semaine
dernière
mille quatre cent trente postes en moins
rien que sur la france le site de vélizy
va fermer et didier ringot délégués du
personnel délégué syndical cgt est sur
ce plateau
il nous donnera son sentiment c'est l'un
des invités de ce 22 octobre nous
parlerons sport également la chronique
sport avec anthony rech bonsoir anthony
salle wilfrid au menu ce soir nous
reviendrons donc sur les championnats
départementaux de taekwondo qui ont eu
lieu à andrésy ce week-end où le tk des
78 a trusté tous les podiums
nous parlerons aussi tennis avec le club
de chevreuse qui ouvre son premier pôle
compétition et enfin du roller hockey
avec les chocs d'elancourt l'entraîneur
de l'équipe fanion sera avec nous sur ce
plateau pour décrypter leur bon début de
saison et les structures mises en place
à l'intersaison et puis comme d'habitude
les résultats du week-end tous les
résultats du week end les interviews la
chronique le sport c'est dans une
vingtaine de minutes dont le 7 8 sur tv
fils on passe à présent au titre en
images le site alcatel vélizy je vous le
disais va fermer ses portes
il emploie 2000 salariés tous ne seront
pas licenciés certains rejoindront un
autre site dans l'essonne c'est la
douche froide pour les syndicats dans le
monde alcatel lucent a annoncé plus de
5000 suppressions de postes dont 1400
rien que pour la france à l'association
média handicap partenaires comme tous
les ans de la semaine du handicap c'est
à montigny
le bretonneux son objectif changer le
regard sur le handicap à travers le
soutien notamment de personnalités est
cette année le mannequin noémie lenoir a
participé à la manifestation
le gymnase chantal mauduit de magny les
hameaux fermé jusqu'à nouvel ordre le
auvent s'est affaissé il ya une dizaine
de jours d été ont été posées un bureau
de contrôle doit maintenant en valider
l'installation le gymnase construit en
1999 il est assez récent il a déjà connu
de nombreux soucis techniques il
s'appelle xavier delpy la 35 ans ce
licencié du club de plongée de 50 ans et
champion de france en appelez nous
l'avons rencontré dans le bassin de
conflans sainte honorine la wii se
prépare avant les championnats d'europe
qui se déroule le week-end prochain
tous ces sujets seront donc développé
dans cette édition du 7 8 je recevrai
également lé responsable du pallium avec
cette question l'accompagnement en fin
de vie et il ya six coups d'oeil en cas
il est conseiller municipal à montigny
il est surtout l'auteur d'un ouvrage un
petit baobab pour vivre ensemble un
livre sur son parcours du sénégal à la
france et on commence avec cette
déclaration d'henri guaino qui relance
les débats autour du 17 octobre 1961
c'est une manifestation qui a mal tourné
il y avait des agitateurs des deux côtés
interrogé sur france inter le député ump
de la 3e circonscription des yvelines a
appelé à ne pas tomber dans l'engrenage
de la repentance
rappelons que le 17 octobre 1961 en
pleine guerre d'algérie une
manifestation était organisée à paris
par la fédération de france du fln
manifestations pour l'indépendance
réprimées violemment par la police
dirigée par le préfet de l'époque
maurice pas pour nous avons en ligne
henri pouillot bonsoir vous êtes membre
du collectif 17 octobre 61 également
membre du comité directeur national de
l'association républicaine des anciens
combattants comment réagissez vous à ces
propos d'henri guaino c'était ce matin
sur france inter lorsqu'il parle d'une
manifestation qui a mal dégénéré avec
des agitateurs des deux côtés
la champagne à paris et que les fuites
faty fier de cette manière les
événements de septembre
alors c'est vrai qu'il y avait déjà eu
cette habitude par rapport aux africains
dans le discours de dakar qu'il avait
préparé pour ça mais le 17 octobre ya
pas d agitateurs de côté les algériens
qui sont défendues à 3000 personnes
étaient tous endimanchés
il n'y avait pas à ceux commis fouet
mais quoi que ce soit un bâton ni autres
tout avait été contrôlé et l'algérien
était descendu très pacifiquement pour
manifester pour compter sur eux c'est le
fera si ce sont des propos qui vous ont
choqué interpellé en tout cas ce matin
d'henri guaino surtout qu'il n'a pas
fait que tu as a qu'à la radio il l'a
fait chier au nouvel observateur avec
les terrains ce même type d'intégration
et c'est vraiment choquant de la part
d'un personnage qui a vu cet important
chantier vissé et qui aujourd'hui
continue à falsifier l'histoire de cette
manière c'est vraiment gagner cette
année dignité et qui aujourd'hui se
trouve à puget que m les agitateurs jeu
sur un socle en projet la semaine
dernière l'elysée a publié un communiqué
de françois hollande on pouvait y lire
la république reconnaît avec lucidité et
s'est fait 51 ans après la tragédie je
rends hommage à la mémoire des victimes
et c'est d'ailleurs ces propos qui ont
entraîné ce dans my hainaut ce matin
elle a aussi votre sentiment sur ces
propos du gouvernement de françois
hollande c'est une avancée en tout cas
dans la reconnaissance par l'état
français de ces événements tout à fait
j'ai un premier pas très important très
intéressant enfin 50 ans après que l'on
puisse reconnaître la responsabilité de
la police française de la république et
d'un jeu ma fac lequel générés dans
l'épreuve 1 400 algériens
moi c'est pas bien le nom puisque les
assises ne soit toujours pas ouverte à
ce sujet c'est super important
par contre il ya des actes qui sont pas
encore un été en adéquation avec chute
démarche de reconnaissance je pense à
l'inauguration de la cité de mauvaise
humeur après juste que prévu 7 nous curé
dans quelques jours fréjus parlez vous
de la défense je suis commande tout à
fait inacceptables merci henri pouillot
pour ses premières déclarations vous
serez demain sur ce plateau nous aurons
l'occasion de revenir sur ceux là 17
octobre 1961 sur ses propos donc d'henri
guaino ce 17 octobre 61 est une
manifestation qui a mal tourné il a ce
matin sur france inter dénoncé un
engrenage du gouvernement engagé dans la
repentance s'est entamée par le
gouvernement selon lui et puisque l'on
parle de ce député ump de la 3e
circonscription elle sachez qu'il a
choisi de soutenir jean françois copé
face à françois fillon dans une
interview donnée au parisien il précise
celui qui serait lui ne sera pas le chef
le leader naturel comme a pu l'être
nicolas sarkozy il ne commandera pas il
présidera on se souvient aussi qu'en et
guaino avait souhaité se présenter pour
cette présidence de l'ump mais faute de
parrainages il avait donc retiré sa
candidature et ce soutien donc à jean
françois copé peut apparaître comme une
surprise élections pour la présidence de
l'ump
ce sera le 18 novembre nous revenons à
présent sur la suppression des postes à
alcatel lucent et la fermeture du site
de vélizy programmée dès l'an prochain